the arm
turns
either to the outside
or to the inside
and at the extremes the grip gets
compromised
so you see the fingers open
and the fingers start to open
at which point the grip is more easily
to disarm
just work the concept turn it inside
[Music]
if you need a technique you need your
thinking techniques it's called
to the outside
and the heel to the inside but we're not
doing a technique we're just working a
concept turn the grip to the outside
compromise it outwardly
compromise it inwardly
outwardly
inwardly
okay
next concept once the grip is
compromised use the leverage
of the knife
push it out through the compromised
fingers at a right angle
out it will come
compromise
use the lever push it out at a right
angle
to the compromise for it so you wouldn't
come back this way
it goes right angle to the compromised
grip
right
outwardly compromise right angle to the
compromised grip
inwardly compromised
[Music]
again don't worry about the techniques
just work the concept
right now i'm using my hand to do this
okay here we go
so same thing compromising outwardly
last time using your hand this time
we're going to use our forearm
the outside of my forearm warm outside
of my forearm
pull
this way
and compromise it inward
compromise forearm
compromised forearm at the right angle
is
and going outward
and here this way
[Music]
my body
foreign
bring in
again just a concept
okay
the next next uh concept is to cut the
thumb
cut the thumb
that's your this song
i'm going in
i probably cut the thumb
this way
so that's with a
reverse
oh we can go with the front too
this way
here this one cut here
oh
[Music]
okay